how am i supposed to choose
what color to do so i've been seeing all
over tik tok people putting tinsel in
their hair and i need it now
i need it it adds a little bit of spice
to the hair i cannot commit to dyeing my
hair right now my hair used to be purple
someday i'll go back but i can't commit
to that right now and so what i want is
something to spice up my hair what could
that be you guessed it tinsel i've seen
very many people do this very many ways
i found one particular girl i like the
way she did it so we're gonna do it how
she does it
let's take a look hey guys today i'm
gonna show you how to put hair tinsel in
your hair all my supplies is ordered off
amazon and here's what you need beads
that match your hair color
this hair tool and of course hair tinsel
of your choice
literally
so many
how am i supposed to choose
what color to do we're going for subtle
but spicy we're gonna do this one i'm a
little stressed the first step is taking
your piece of hair tinsel and tying the
bead in a knot at the bottom
[Music]
it should look like this where the bead
hangs from utensil when you're not
next step is to thread the bead with the
hair tinsel through the hair tool like
this i'm supposed to put the
hair tint like this
next with the hair hook you'll find the
perfect piece of hair
okay it hook onto the hair and then pull
this through
[Music]
like that next you just take your hair
clampers on the bead like so clamp it
and then you're done okay
[Music]
this is not as easy as she says it is
ma'am
[Music]
no
it's definitely not supposed to
let's try that again
okay
i'm going to clamp it flat
[Music]
i did it
you can barely see it but look
i did it
oh my gosh tinsel in my hair i always
trim it to match my hair length we'll
just do a little
it's a
and here's how it looks fun
okay let's do some more
[Music]
if you have a hard time with it then
suddenly you're good at it
real ego boost i'll tell you
[Music]
okay so
here is the final product i
do like it a lot i think because of the
color i chose it is really subtle but i
just love
the little pops of sparkle it'll be fun
to try more brighter colors but for now
i love this so let's see how long this
lasts and then we'll come back to remove
them
i love it so far okay so it's been about
a week that i've had the tinsel in my
hair and honestly i loved it we've had a
few casualties we've had a few
casualties now i have washed my hair
i have dried my hair i have used my blow
dryer brush
they've stayed in my hair for this whole
week so to get these out
we're gonna follow some instructions i
know of two ways that are super
effective of getting it out first method
is honestly what i do the most and that
is just find it and just pull it out
like literally that easy now if you have
some pieces that are clamped a little
bit tighter where that method doesn't
work here's how to get them out so this
is a piece that's a little bit tighter
as you can see it doesn't want to come
out so you're going to take the same
hair tool you used to put it in and
you're going to squeeze it the opposite
direction okay we're going to squeeze it
in the opposite direction i have it in
the clamp i'm just going to squeeze it
open
and once you squeeze it open you should
just be able to pull it up
straight out
okay
that
should
be all of them
hair still looks the same things are
good so
10 out of 10 recommend
if you want to spice up your hair but
subtly spice up your hair put some
tinsel in it
put some tinsel in it
the best thing
once you get them out
you can really get a good head
scratching
oh yeah
you